El escritor de Hebreos
Nos demuestra que el Nuevo Testamento es un cumplimiento de las sombras que el Antiguo Testamento da,
Mostrando que el Antiguo Testamento, los ritos y toda la ley de moises es una sombra
De la vida que tenemos en Cristo Jesus;
Pero con una diferencia: la palabra clave en Hebreos es la palabra: MEJOR
Porque el cumplimiento es mejor que la sombra, ¿amen?
¿Quien quiere vivir en la sombra?, ¿Quien quiere dedicarse a la sombra?
O sea, aqui en esta plataforma mi cuerpo esta haciendo una sombra aqui sobre la pared
Y uno  podria estudiar la sombra y descubrir muchas cosas, una cosa que yo noto aqui es que esa persona tiene anteojos
Uno podria escudriñar la sombra, Si aprender muchas cosas y no hay mentira en la sombra,
¿Pero porque estudiar la sombra tanto? No estoy diciendo que no debemos estudiar el antiguo, no, no, no,
¿Porque meternos en lo de la sombra, cuando podemos meternos en la vida?
¿Quien hace la sombra del antiguo? Pablo dice: Cristo mismo; y la vida que  hay en El, ¿amen?
No vayan a entender mal, no estoy minimizando la importancia del Antiguo Testamento en ningun momento,
Es mas como seres humanos muy terrenales y carnales, es imposible entender lo espiritual
Sin entender lo terrenal, que el antiguo nos da y nos revela, imposible.